bonjour mesdames et messieurs je
m'appelle le gui bois je suis le chef de
pupitre à l'espace autochtone à
radio-canada bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale à l'occasion de la journée
nationale des peuples autochtones
le thème choisi par l'espace autochtones
cette année la réconciliation le chemin
parcouru le chemin qui reste à faire
la question de la réconciliation qui a
marqué les administrations du
gouvernement trudeau
il n'y a pas de relation plus importante
pour mon gouvernement que la relation
avec les peuples autochtones at il écrit
et dit à de multiples reprises nous
inviter pour cette émission spéciale
d'abord édith cloutier et les la
directrice générale du centre d'amitié
autochtone de val d'or madame cloutier
bienvenu merci d'être là et puis le chef
de l'assemblée des premières nations
québec labrador ghislain picard chef
picard merci d'être là
bienvenue alors avant de commencer nous
allons nous petit voyage dans le temps
nous reporter à 2010 lorsque le premier
ministre a livré un discours ou nations
unies un discours qui portait justement
sur la réconciliation et du mi6 n'a
connu de tous mais l'info people alors
le premier ministre qui parlait de
véritable réconciliation édith cloutier
on va commencer avec vous est ce qu'on a
fait du chemin depuis ce temps là depuis
2010 est est ce qu on a avancé sur ce
chemin de la réconciliation
mais d'abord je veux me gouache de cette
invitation et vous dire que je
je suis sur mon territoire traditionnel
anishnabe un territoire non céder donc
ça me fait plaisir de partager cette
tribune avec le chef picard aujourd'hui
et de souhaiter à tous et à toutes une
bonne journée nationale des peuples
autochtones à val d'or on le célébrait
hier avec le beau soleil sur le site qui
n'abritent donc un bon moment de
rassemblement dans le respect des règles
sanitaires évidemment mais bon on a pu
souligner le solstice d'été hier dans ce
beau dimanche ensoleillé
donc oui la réconciliation depuis 2010
il donc l'extrait que vous avez montré à
se met beaucoup d'espoir je pense que ce
gouvernement et l'allocution du premier
ministre à l'onu permis de pouvoir
prendre la mesure à ce moment là donc de
cette volonté gouvernementale de faire
des pas concrets dans cette
réconciliation
la réconciliation je considère qu'elle
est
quelle est la responsabilité de tous et
de toutes
on sait qu'on a la commission vérité
réconciliation avec ses appels à
l'action qui a donc évité la société
canadienne la société autochtone le
gouvernement a marché dans la voie de la
réconciliation
donc pour qu'il y ait réconciliation il
faut avoir une reconnaissance de ce qui
ce qui obligea c'est vrai que
réconciliation donc on a quand même
encore du chemin à faire
comme société dont qui est d'abord
d'apprendre à connaître l'histoire des
peuples autochtones notre histoire
commune comme société canadienne est le
meilleur exemple qu'on a c'est le choc
à travers le pays de la découverte de
ces 215 1275 pardon restes d'enfants
quand nous où on dirait que les gens ont
été nombreux à prendre son histoire des
pensionnaires pourtant on a une
commission vérité réconciliation on a
plusieurs témoignages dans l'actualité
on entend beaucoup donc il ya encore du
chemin
oui bon chef picard vous êtes aux
premières lignes
finalement vous êtes en discussion quasi
permanente autant avec le gouvernement
fédéral qu'avec le gouvernement du
québec
alors pour vous est ce que vous avez
senti au delà des mots une volonté des
dirigeants des gouvernements d'aller
vers cette réconciliation
non mon tour de vous souhaiter mission
mutation à tous et à toutes
mais petit également la peau de l'espace
est pas mais à nous souhaiter à tous une
belle journée nationale des peuples
autochtones étaient jeunes damas il ya
la réalité politique qui est vérité
incontournable et vous référer à cette
sortie du premier ministre canadien
devant les états rassemblés au sein de
l'onu en 2017 et j'ai tendance à la
mettre en perspective
celle où une tentative plutôt de
représentation 2d ce carré qui est un
chef
cayuga un chef traditionnel des eaux des
mers chaudes qui avait déjà tenté de
sensibiliser à l'époque ça s'appelait la
ligue des nations en 1923 et donc il y
avait ce ce que j'appellerais 7
ce désir qui qui a toujours qui est
demeuré l'eau depuis depuis ses années
l'ordination d'avoir cette
reconnaissance au niveau international
donc si on compare les années on on peut
peut-être se faire un peu pc ds par
rapport au résultat de la réconciliation
en même temps c'est vrai que je pense
que la personne qui peut nier que
lorsque monsieur trudeau a été élu pour
la première fois du week-end il y avait
pas de gouvernement qui le précédait qui
sans s'être rendus aussi loin qu'il leur
fait autant dans les intentions que dans
des actions comme qui ont été menées
d'ailleurs pour une première fois mon
avis on code d'honneur en fonction de ce
que j'ai connu observé pour la première
fois un premier ministre a pris la peine
de donner des délais demande très très
clair à l'ensemble des ministres du de
son cabinet mais si on sait quelque
chose je pense que personne ne peut
contredire même six années plus tard
mais en même temps ce qu'il faut
reconnaître aussi c'est
l'espèce de d'emprise un peu
colonialiste que l'état au toujours
envers les peuples autochtones et ça
certains démontrer oui par certains du
milieu politique s'est démentie aussi
par la bureaucratie et il faisait
référence un peu plus tôt la la
découverte qui nous ont tous insisté il
ya trois semaines d piété port qui était
pas l histoire nouvelle et c'est la même
chose pour la journée que nous célébrons
aujourd'hui le 21 juin qui est encore
qu'ils aient pas encore qui pas encore
devenu un réflexe alors que sera-t-il
light ça fait 25 ans est à nous pouvait
que laisser libre et donc pour moi il ya
tout ça ça nous remet peut-être comme
société devant l'édifice devrait se
poser un nouveau lieu de culte iman
uniquement compter sur le processus
politique parce que c'est aussi une
affaire de ceux-ci vous et allons-y
concrètement et je vais aller de votre
côté madame cloutier
une des choses qui a marqué
l'administration trudeau c'était cette
enquête nationale sur les femmes
autochtones assassinées et disparues et
beaucoup de recommandations mais on a
l'impression que ça bouge pas beaucoup
d'une part il ya un préjugé favorable
qui s'affiche de la part du gouvernement
fédéral mais d'autre part sur le terrain
peut-être à cause de la bureaucratie
ce à quoi faisait référence le chef
picard
on a l'impression qu'on a beaucoup de
difficultés à mettre de l'avant des
mesures concrètes mais je pense qu
apporter d'aidé transformation
systémique des changements système et
que ça demande du temps ça demande
l'investissement à sa demande surtout
une volonté d'agir faut se rappeler que
lorsque la commission des femmes filles
autochtones à satiné disparu avait
déposé son rapport à ce moment là on a
sans détour parlé d'un génocide points
et je me souviens que ça la pause et un
mal
dans la lah on a pu découvrir en lisant
le rapport
je sens des pailles au stick on a une
définition
alors donc voilà on est devant
aujourd'hui ce terme qui qui prend du
sens alors qu'on fait la découverte et
on continue à faire des découvertes
d'enfants de fausses d'enfants qui ont
été qui sont morts alors que c'était
qu'ils étaient sous la responsabilité de
l'église et de l'état
oui des enfants qui ont été arrachés à
leurs familles absolument oui
j'explique à vous en avez fait allusion
et vous n'êtes pas le premier à dire
cette chose-là et des chefs m'en ont
parlé d d d d d intervenants autochtones
en ont parlé
la différence entre le discours affiché
par les hommes et des femmes politiques
du gouvernement libéral et d'autre part
la réponse de la bureaucratie fédérale
est ce que on peut parler de coupure
entre le discours politique et la
machine adaptée
on y faisait référence un peu plus tôt à
cette découverte
chez nous c'est l'ouest trois semaines
environ
et c'est clair que oui avait le rôle
dominant des acteurs politiques de
l'époque mais il y avait aussi la
bureaucratie qui était au premier chef
responsable de l'application de la
politique est un homme est calme
rappelons que c'est il renie pas
quelqu'un qui est fameux célèbre au pays
de l'or
c est ce de ses capacités littéraire
mais en même temps ça a été le premier à
woodstock
kemball dans une scop qui était vraiment
l'artisan est celui qui a mis en oeuvre
la politique des pensionnats indiens au
pays et il n'était pas seul mais c'est
celle que vous passiez à laquelle je
faisais référence
un peu plus tôt mais ceci dit c'est
clairement il ya cette nouvelle qui
sortent qui sort depuis les quarante
huit dernières heures sur le rôle de
l'église dans les abus sexuels sexuelles
contre des milliers de québécois et donc
c'est aussi vrai pour nous et parce que
l'église a joué un rôle prédominant
également dans cette danse est politique
d'assimilation et en ce qui concerne je
pense que si on doit vraiment donné à la
réconciliation tout son sens
mais on doit être prêt à tout remettre
en question est ce que je dis souvent
puis je parle la nécessité d'une
véritable révolution dans nos façons de
faire
parce que pour moi lorsqu'on regarde
2015 aujourd'hui ben ya bien bien des
processeurs qui ont été ralentis parce
que la bureaucratie n'était pas
nécessairement au rendez vous malgré la
volonté d'un point de vue politique
oui grenon la question des femmes madame
cloutier est ce que c'est le même
phénomène est ce que on sent un blocage
de la part des autorités
même à la suite de ce rapport qui est
loin d'être ambivalent on parle de génos
aidons à 12 cents femmes et semble celle
que ça continue là parce que pour avoir
rencontré des organisations au manitoba
semble-t-il que des femmes disparues des
femmes assassinées ça s'est pas arrêtée
avec le dépôt du rapport est ce que vous
sentez ça et deep une espèce de blocage
moi j'ai du monde communauté autochtone
du québec et du canada laissant d'amitié
autochtone nous sommes des organisations
de première ligne donc que le chef du
camp le mentionner ça va prendre plus au
delà de la vie
voie politique pour pour contribuer à
apporter des changements importants et
améliorer la qualité de vie des
autochtones et des femmes et des filles
et des enfants des familles alors le
mouvement des centres d'amitié
autochtones est en première ligne mais
nous sommes dans l'action au quotidien
nous sommes des organisations de
mobilisation communautaire dans les
villes qui facilite justement notamment
l'accès à des services mais aussi à
mobiliser des citoyens citoyennes des
premières nations les inuits et métis à
travers le pays
apprendre à occuper des espaces des
espaces communautaires pour me mettre de
l'avant des initiatives portées par les
autochtones man
donc oui il ya des ralentissements qui
peuvent être qu'ils peuvent être dues à
ce que vous mentionnez toute la notion
de bureaucratie mais aussi les enjeux
politiques mais sur le plan
communautaire
nous tentons d'occuper ces espaces entre
ces deux là et de faire cheminer des
projets de société autochtone et dans ce
cas-ci un projet de société autochtone
urbain qui se traduit par par le
développement d'initiatives en
habitations communautaires des
initiatives en petite enfance des
initiatives culturelles alors c'est
cette façon là que moi je vois dans le
rôle que je joue dans le rôle que les
centres d'amitié autochtones du québec
et du canada la place qu'on occupe en
première ligne pour faire avancer
progresser faire progresser la
réconciliation
bon on parle de réconciliation la
réconciliation c'est un flic ça postule
une relation avec l'autre nécessairement
l'altérité
alors est ce que les québécois ont
avancé sur le plat de la réconciliation
et gabriel paul qui est notre
journaliste à espace autochtone qui est
allé à la rencontre de quelques uns on
les écoute on devrait commencer au
primaire au secondaire 1 puis ça
aiderait justement
la réconciliation cette ville établi une
correspondance avec une classe de
mistissini et mes élèves avaient aucune
conscience que ces gens n'existait leur
mode de vie
ce qu'il faisait à l'école il n'y avait
même pas conscience qu'ils pouvaient
aller à l'école pour us était encore les
tipis et la forêt là évidemment autour
sur un point fondamental qui est celui
de l'éducation chef picard escaut et
puis s'est défoncé des portes ouvertes
de dire on devrait changer les
programmes actuellement d'enseignement
d'histoire et on en parle beaucoup
depuis quelques semaines et pour moi
c'est très craint que aussi aussi sombre
que qu'ils soient de l'échappée des
pensionnats autochtones ou pays l'on
doit faire partie intégrante du cursus
ce qu'on a accès c'est trop important
c'est quand même une étape marquante
pour les mauvaises raisons de notre
histoire qui s'est échelonnée sur plus
d'un siècle et pour moi c'était à mon
avis c'est un incontournable
de façon plus large je vais vous relater
une expérience vécue il ya déjà
plusieurs années alors que la ville de
québec était dirigée par la mairesse feu
en brie boucher et qui a envoyé lé mans
une très très candidement que
lorsqu'elle a grandi à tout jeune
l'histoire qu'elle connaissait c'est
celle qui débute en encaissant 34 mary
est ce qu'elle a avoué c'est que il ya
toute une histoire qui précède celle là
et je pense que c'est là où je ne sais
qui encore beaucoup de terrain à couvrir
le pour arriver à a par exemple des
programmes d'éducation qui soit à la
hauteur de la présence et de la
contribution des peuples cape town dans
l'édification du québec du pays
et le pire dans tout ça c'est que
imaginez moi veut dire un large que j'ai
aujourd'hui j'ai appris la main histoire
donc une histoire qui ont complètement
finalement contribué à dévaloriser
l'époque que nous que nous étions donc
le phénomène d'assimilation s'est même
poursuivie jusqu'à tout récemment et je
pense que oui il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à changer l'eau sans vouloir être
pessimiste à outrance je pense qu'on a
encore beaucoup de terrain très fort ça
d'ailleurs que l'année dernière
lorsqu'on aura vu nos placements
d'actions contre le racisme public
on a beaucoup beaucoup insisté sur le
travail qui doit se faire à la base pour
110 engagé le milieu politique
mais à la base c'est vraiment la
relation de société à société cibox a
cependant c'est pour nous c'est
important que ça soit que ça soit qu'il
y ait une référence par rapport à cette
réalité là d'ailleurs le sondage que
nous avons mené qui nous a aidé à bâtir
le plan a été très très révélateur à
l'effet que il ya encore beaucoup de
méconnaissance
mais ceci dit aussi une meilleure
compréhension des enjeux qui sont des
noms qui sonnent dirais que c'est quand
même très très encourageant comme les
autres oui madame cloutier vous êtes en
milieu urbain
milieu de val d'or lieu de convergence
pour plusieurs nations autochtones on
pense vous ou et on pense aux années
schnabel
on pense à la nation crie vous êtes aux
premières loges
est-ce que vous avez vu une évolution
vous entre la relation entre les
autochtones et les non autochtones en
milieu urbain est-ce que vous avez vu
cette évolution nous moi j'ai le grand
privilège de servir ma communauté
il s'évada mais aussi les à travers le
québec en ville depuis plus de 30 ans
maintenant dans un mouvement qui est le
mouvement des centaines d'autochtones
qui existe au québec depuis cinquante
ans plus de 60 ans canada est au coeur
même de la mission des centres d'amitié
autochtones
nous avons le rapprochement entre les
peuples
donc notre mission elle est elle mise
sur justement la création d'espacés de
lieux communs où on peut favoriser cet
échange là l'exemple du centre d'amitié
autochtone nous avons fondé une garderie
donc un cpe qui est super autochtone
dans les murs entame édition toc tonnes
mais dont les portes sont ouvertes
depuis plus de vingt ans maintenant à
des enfants non autochtone des familles
non autochtone donc ce sont les non
autochtones qui viennent en immersion
dans une culture qui la culture
anishnabe et donc les premiers enfants à
fréquenter le cpe
aujourd'hui à 16 17 18 ans alors moi je
pense que c'est c'est d'époque comme
celui là également qui contribue à
changer les mentalités à changer notre
société à être plus ouverte sur sur les
autochtones et donc c'est comme ça aussi
qu'on tisse des alliances et des
solidarités avec le temps oui mais il
reste quand même certains blocages et
revu
1 lors de la dernière enquête l enquête
du coroner sur la mort de madame et
chaque fois non neuvic avait des
blocages en cas il y avait du racisme
institutionnel qui rentrait par tous les
pores des institutions là
particulièrement on l'a vu à l'hôpital
de joliette 7,7 difficultés du
gouvernement du québec par exemple de
parler ne serait-ce que de parler de
racisme systémique
il reste quand même des blocages madame
cloutier si vous voulez oui d'accord
bien oui on a vu et puis je pense que
c'est une c'est une épisode qui a
bouleversé le québec le canada est
l'histoire de joyce et chaque point de
dépasser les frontières du canada
donc oui le racisme systémique la
commission vient s'est penché sur la
question des relations les services
publics et des autochtones comme ça
revient par de discrimination systémique
dans ce cas-ci et apporte de plusieurs
appels à l'action pour pour que
justement ont contribué à ces
changements là mais ce que je retiens de
se répandre
entre autres choses c'est que les
autochtones doivent être mis au coeur
des solutions pour contrer le racisme
systémique
nous avons des institutions nous sommes
en mesure de mettre de l'avant des
solutions mais nous devons avoir la
collaboration des gouvernements à val
d'or on a annoncé ministre la première
annoncée il ya quelques semaines un
investissement substantiel dans un
modèle de clinique en santé autochtone
qui est un projet qui a l'initiative qui
est porté par le centre d'amitié mais
maintenant qui va se transposer ailleurs
au québec dans d'autres villes mais une
initiative qui a été porté par le centre
d'amitié à bout de bras pendant dix ans
et qui n'est qu'il n'avait pas de
financement on avait le soutien du
gouvernement fédéral pour développer le
modèle
alors on a pu maintenant atterrir avec
l'initiative co construite avec de
l'abitibi-témiscamingue donc je pense et
en travaillant ensemble mais en donnant
vraiment la place aux autochtones de
mettre de l'avant des initiatives qui
leur conviennent oui chef picard je vais
revenir à vous parce que vous avez vu
passer plusieurs administrations
provinciales vous un québec
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
à chaque fois de faire faire oeuvre de
pédagogie réexpliqué les mêmes choses
aux nouvelles administrations au nouveau
gouvernement à la nouvelle ministre au
nouveau ministre des affaires
autochtones
mais non vous vous tenez vous venez de
fond d'une réponse dans votre question
en quelque sorte où effectivement on a
toujours l'impression de devenir
l'horloge à 0 lorsqu'on est devant une
nouvelle administration mais encore que
parti nous les enjeux évolué il peut
être pas aussi rapidement puis de façon
aussi concrètes qu'on souhaiterait mais
ce qui est ce qui est sans doute encore
plus désolant c'est le fait que il ya eu
des questions de principe là et on
insiste beaucoup sur l'importance des
principes d'un art caractère
incontournable surtout lorsqu'on voit
les choses de nos lunettes à nous de
notre ville est à nous et c'est lors
qu'on al'impression houdoud de
progresser mais on reste figée dans le
temps ou même je dirais que dans
certains cas on régresse et fait
aujourd'hui je vous parle de sites coûts
et à la main quand des peuples
autochtones qui se tient annuellement
depuis quatre ans maintenant à québec et
que démarche que nous avons initié
c'était en 2017 et qui visait justement
à permettre à la population de venir à
la rencontre des peuples autochtones de
venir à la rencontre de leur diversité
donc
j'ajoute soit pour des cas il ne faut
pas non plus compter entièrement sur les
gouvernements
favoriser le rapprochement nécessaire au
niveau sociétal c'est bien ensemble à
tous les jours pas d'abord peut-être pas
de la façon qu'on m'aurait souhaité
pendant les cinq derniers siècles
mais il y en deux mois pour moins que la
réalité est telle qu'elle se présente
aujourd'hui
donc ce que samedi c'est que toutes les
tentatives de d'éradiquer les
protecteurs de les assimiler ont
totalement totalement échoué
donc je pense que inouïe nous est donnée
aujourd'hui cette opportunité l'aude de
rapprochement et de connaître de le
connaître ou nation à travers leur
culture leur identité leur diversité
également je pense que ceci étant le
processus politique continue à un peu ce
qu'il est on est loin d'avoir ce que
j'appellerais peut-être l'idéal parce
que et ça je me permet d'adapter ça
parce que c'est tellement mes yeux qui
est extrêmement important parce que tout
le monde de toute évidence a applaudi
l'adoption de la loi c-15 ou parlement
fédéral par le sénat la semaine dernière
qui qui qui concerne la déclaration de
l'onu sur les droits des peuples
autochtones est un de ceux évidemment
nous on en sait également à pourvoir
vaut connaître ses progrès l'homme et en
même temps on aurait souhaité qu'ils
fait savoir un langage un peu plus un
peu plus engageant un peu plus
contraignant pour le gouvernement ce qui
n'a pas été le cas
donc on a une loi fédérale avec un
gouvernement provincial où le premier
ministre dit que selon ce qu'il entend
de ses avocats l'ipo question qu'on
aille sur ce très long parce qu'il est
beaucoup trop en glissant donc encore
une fois la bureaucratie qui viennent de
se mêler de tout ça et c'est ça aussi
des fils c'est que pour moi si on
n'assure pas les conditions nécessaires
pour que les gouvernements que nous
représentons soit pleinement autonomes
donc avec une capacité au niveau
territorial
on voit toujours tomber à courser sans
problème si c'est que on est là dessus
le fédéral la province loge dans la même
pièce bon si je mens progrès qu'on n'a
pas vu parce qu'il faut pas oublier
qu'avant la pandémie il y avait une
autre crise voyez celle de la crise
seront bien comme on l'a appelé mais qui
m était évidemment en évidence un
contentieux et italien l'ont qui perdure
depuis beaucoup trop bien évidemment
l'on touche à l'enjeu fondamental à
l'enjeu fondamental celui qui devrait
mener à l'autonomie gouvernementale
passe nécessairement par le territoire
ça c'est fondamental et à chaque fois
d'ailleurs qu'il ya un conflit il ya
toujours le territoire qui pointe son
nez
écoutons justement le premier ministre
trudeau qui nous parle d'autonomie
gouvernementale
le moment est venu de sortir des
sentiers battus de faire abstraction des
limites imposées par de vieilles
structures coloniales désuète pour faire
place à la nouveauté à des structures
qui respecteront les droits inhérents
les autochtones à s'autogouverner et à
déterminer leur propre avenir
bon ben c'est tout le monde est d'accord
si le premier ministre est d'accord pour
l'autonomie gouvernementale si les
nations autochtones sont d'accord où ça
bloque chef picard secret on parle
d'autonomie de façon un peu plus
concrète depuis depuis peut-être des 30
dernières années avec des mesures des
politiques aussi qui doivent guider le
gouvernement fédéral a qu'on vient
d'entendre avec les communautés
à ma connaissance une chute sans doute
genève un peu la carte des communautés
qui sont qui sont engagés dans cette
danse et processus aujourd'hui donc il
ya encore une grande majorité
communautés qui sont et demeurent un peu
sur le jour de la loi sur les indiens
mais ceci étant dit c'est important
quand même de reconnaître que le
processus doit doit prendre le temps qui
est nécessaire parce que il faut pas
oublier que le processus de
décolonisation est un processus qui est
extrêmement ardu et on parle on parle
pas assez souvent des communautés des
membres qui les constituent et pour
ça passe beaucoup par ce qu'on appelle
en bon français le parlement et saunier
main à mon sens ce qui est indéniable ça
c'est un processus qui appartient non
seulement communauté mais également aux
individus et ça c'est important de ne
pas sous-estimer les faons que ça prend
l'énergie que ça que ça demande surtout
un regard de des bouleversements que lui
nation connu là depuis les 150 200
dernières années pour moi c'est un
aspect important ça passe aussi par
reconnaître les choses telles qu'elles
sont et je parlais de la déclaration un
peu plus tôt de la loi fédérale qui est
maintenant de loi c-15 et pour moi c'est
important d'insister sur ce qu'ils
méritent d'être vraiment mis à l'avant
plan en termes de processus notamment la
question de vraiment mettre le couvert
sur cette doctrine de la découverte qui
est passablement révolues mais qui est
quand même lit aux problèmes que je cite
un peu plus tôt c'est à dire que c'est
c'est vraiment une doctrine qui était
situé par le vatican et qui permettait
finalement découvreurs d'asseoir leur
autorité sur des territoires qu'on
disait inhabitée en le terrain les
lislois et pour moi lancé c'est vraiment
solde des lacunes que nous voyons
aujourd'hui au niveau de l'engagement
réel et concret de la part du
gouvernement pourtant illégale que
provinciaux ouais qu'on le veuille ou
non aussi on s'aperçoit héros et je suis
la question depuis quand même quelques
années qui a quand même un processus
lent et inexorable qui mène vers
l'autonomie gouvernementale vers cette
forme de décolonisation finalement des
peuples autochtones et là dessus en fin
de semaine dans le devoir y avait
quelque chose d'intéressant parce que on
nous parlait d'aimé césaire vous savez
ce grand poète de la martinique qui a
passé une bonne partie de sa vie à se
battre contre la colonisation et voilà
ce qu'ils disent
est de la décolonisation il disait le
temps de la décolonisation sera plus
difficile pour le monde noir parce que
nous n'avons plus à nous dresser contre
un ennemi commun aisément discernable
mis à lutter en nous mêmes contre
nous-mêmes et moi je l'interprète un peu
comme le colonialisme qui s'insère dans
les esprits un de ceux qu'on a colonisé
de ce qu'on a opprimé comment vous
comprenez cette position vous ai dit de
votre côté de votre point de vue vous
savez j'ai vu qu'en parler de ce chemin
vers l'autonomie
je pense que nous sommes nombreux à
pouvoir y contribuer
on parlait de voies diverses
le milieu communautaire autochtone peut
se mobiliser à travers le mouvement
descente amitié au québec comme des
acteurs d'une société civile autochtone
qui qui donne une voix aux citoyens qui
vivent dans les villes vous savez plus
de 50% des membres des premières nations
au québec qui vivent à l'extérieur des
communautés et ensemble on peut
contribuer à l'avancement de nos droits
à faire en sorte qu'on puce dans cette
diversité la contribuer à améliorer la
qualité de vie de nos gens donc et à
reconnaître qu'il peut y avoir à
l'intérieur de ces systèmes de première
nation système des premiers peuples une
diversité de voix mais aussi des modèles
de gouvernance communautaire comme on le
fait à travers les centres d'amitié
autochtones qui sont des modèles de
gouvernance qui mettent de l'avant des
services aux premiers peuples dans un
cadre qui est sécurisant supplante
durrer et donc nous avons alain entre
nous aussi à s'entendre sur ces modèles
de gouvernance complémentaires ces
efforts collectifs confère pour enfin
quand arrivait
atterrir à la même place qui est la
reconnaissance de nos droits de se
donner une capacité d'agir sur sur une
communauté et d'améliorer ses conditions
de vie là donc il ya un chemin là aussi
qu'on a à prendre et a croisé le chemin
à l'intérieur
ces débats qui nous concerne aussi à
l'intérieur de nos sociétés au total
oui chef picard est ce que vous pensez
vous que ce processus de décolonisation
risque d'être aussi très complexes et
que les autochtones ou s'ils devront de
leur côté y mettre tous leurs leur
talent tout leur génie toute leur
imagination
j'allais dire là dessus et en référence
à ce que vous citiez 1 un peu plus tôt
le commentaire qui finalement nos
différences hip hop beaucoup de la
communauté noire où chacun des défis et
des bouleversements que nous avons
connues est ce que j'ajouterai à soi
c'est que j'entende choc d'une fois
d'ailleurs c'est que c'est uniquement
les peuples colonisés qui peuvent se
décoloniser
et c'est pas pour des responsabiliser le
milieu politique
mais il faudra aussi que nos peuples se
dote des moyens nécessaires pour
finalement
et sa liste je dirais comme cela ces
valeurs qui nous ont été enlevés ou
codées sur plusieurs décennies et je
pense que ça c'est un élément important
parce que on peut on peut aimer ou et
pas que nous sommes que nous avons droit
à l'autodétermination que nous sommes
des gouvernements autonomes
encore faudra-t-il que nous en ayons la
capacité et c'est ça à mon avis qui pour
rejoindre un peu votre question sur
notre responsabilité aussi comme société
je pense qu'on est directement
directement interpellé et encore
aujourd'hui on voit que ce soit on le
voit alors que ce soit en milieu urbain
ou en fonte ex de communautés l'eau est
encore un contexte social qui n'est pas
nécessairement idéal
et c'est là que je reviens ce que c'est
un peu plus tôt c'est que j'ai rencontré
monsieur legault quelques temps après
après son élection en 2000 18 m2 trois
semaines et ce qu'il avançait comme
étant ses priorités lorsque sa touche
nos peuples
c'est vraiment la santé l'éducation et
l'économie moi j'ai accroché sur
l'aspect économique parce que pour moi
il économise ses rimes avec accès au
territoire accès aux sources et ça rime
aussi avec partage de la richesse
on les partage de la richesse et qu'on a
mis bas et rim avec une meilleure
1 estime de soi un peu plus important
est un peu plus grand donc je pense que
on peut facilement à faire les titres et
les différentes associations ici par
rapport aux conditions qui devraient
prévaloir pour faire en sorte que nous
communauté éléments qui font partie soit
vraiment dans le siège du conducteur
dans l'exercice de leurs de leur
motoneige
oui en terminant c'est le 21 juin la
journée nationale des peuples
autochtones le 24 juin s'en vient la
journée nationale a fait national des
québécois qu'est ce qu'on pourrait se
souhaiter entre québécois et entre
autochtones pour la prochaine année ou
pour les prochaines années est dit
l'amitié l'amitié entre les peuples
on parle elle d'une journée nationale
des autochtones à québec il ya cet
événement coup et qui est une invitation
à la rencontre également mais je pense
que on est également très choyé par
parce que la culture les arts nous
propose venant des autochtones même en
littérature on voit de plus en plus
d'auteurs autochtone il ya du théâtre il
ya de la musique il ya des expositions
il ya des artistes je pense que la
culture et les enfants sont des portes
d'entrée facilitantes à une meilleure
compréhension et à la connaissance de
soi et d'ailleurs plusieurs expositions
leurs encours donc une invitation à
regarder le spectacle télévisé ce soir à
entendre ces artistes autochtones et non
autochtones à partager une même tribune
et a invité à l'ami à l'amitié chez pika
qu'est-ce qu'on peut se souhaiter belle
reconnaissance mutuelle respect mutuel
surtout je pense que c'est extrêmement
important
et comme au risque de me répéter je
faisais un peu plus tôt on y trouverait
qu'il y ait aussi une référence
automatique à la journée celle
d'aujourd'hui finalement la tournée
nationale des peuples autochtones dans
dans l'esprit des québécois et des
québécoises à l'échelle du québec parce
que c'est vraiment deux deux journées
important qu'ils se côtoient dans
l'année quelques heures à peine et je
pense qu'on aurait un très simplement
avantage à faire valoir
une réalité qui a longtemps montant
était abstraite pour pour plusieurs des
concitoyens québécois québécoise et je
pense que c'est à maintenant l'eau de de
favoriser un peu c'est un changement de
cap
et comme comme le disait dit plus tôt
c'est il ya toutes sortes de courants
possédons maintenant qu'ils peuvent
favoriser le rapprochement au niveau
culturel au niveau artistique également
et on a eu il ya deux ans à peine le
premier prix décerné à des artistes
autochtones dans le cadre du gala de
l'adisq
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
révolutionnaire est pour moi le sam en
évidence ce qu'on a de plus de plus
riches
finalement une culture qui côtoient
celles celle du québec et qui est
capable de se lier d'amitié également
mais ceci étant dit je pense que la
journée d'aujourd'hui la journée la cia
de 6 nous invite finalement à vraiment
favorisé ce rapprochement nom de un
autre merci beaucoup chef picard et dit
cloutier madame cloutier à val-d'or je
vous souhaite une excellente journée
nationale des peuples autochtones à vous
aussi chypre cas merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation je sais que vous êtes
très occupé merci également chez vous un
de nous avoir écoutés et surtout ne
manquez pas de lire espace autochtone
c'est à radio canada merci tout le monde
votre journée
[Musique]